one of the most interesting developments
we've seen in the business world over
the last few years has been the creation
of new kinds of business models in
different parts of the world that we
never would have imagined just a few
years ago and they've taken us all by
surprise when we see these new kinds of
business models being created in
different parts of the world their
innovations that could not have been
created anywhere else
they couldn't have been created in the
Silicon Valley for example because
they're solving problems that are unique
to other parts of the world the world in
a way has become because of
globalization a laboratory for inventing
new business logics technologies are
moving all over the world so that
different kinds of people in different
cultures all have access to information
they have access to technology they have
access to knowledge about businesses but
the particular problems that businesses
are solving are very different I think
the way we want to think about
entrepreneurship in the world
environment right now is that the old
conception that we see business models
that are born in innovative places like
a Silicon Valley and then we take those
and play a kind of business model
arbitrage with the rest of the world
there's game get there are gains to be
made from that kind of of arbitrage but
they're actually quite limited compared
to immersing ourselves in the context of
other places and seeing what potential
they hold I remember being in Baja
California sewer so they down many
people in the audience may have been to
Cabo and so forth for vacations but if
you go inland and go into the rural
areas there there are several companies
but there was one innovative company
that moved there to make soap out of the
cactus and the soap made from that
cactus
does a tremendous job cleaning sheets
without using bleach and it turns out
this is then a big hit in the hotel
business worldwide so while it was born
of Baja
California sewer because they have all
this cactus it was a product that could
be used everywhere and of course once
you see it used there you realize well
now there's another crop or another
product that can be made from cactus
other than tequila in the form of this
soap and of course the entrepreneur
involved has been tremendously
successful from it but you wouldn't
think of that if you were in any other
context so many of the new
entrepreneurial ventures we see going on
in the world are very much a product of
the context within which these
organizations are born if you take
Taobao for example part of Alibaba in
China when they were first getting
started they were there in the consumer
to consumer and the business to consumer
internet space very similar to eBay or
some parts of it to amazon.com but when
they were trying to get started they
quickly realized that the lack of having
a base of consumers who use credit cards
was making their life very difficult
meanwhile eBay had PayPal Amazon
obviously uses credit cards much of the
rest of the internet world was able to
rely on a customer base in places like
Western Europe or the United States
where many people had a credit card
millions and millions of consumers and
China did not have credit cards now they
are getting them at an increasing pace
but they still lag behind especially
when compared to their increasing
purchasing power so Alibaba and Jack Ma
his team in finding a solution to the
credit-card problem came up with Olli
pay very much in the same way that
mercado libre in brazil although it's
based in argentina its operations are
mainly in brazil in other parts of latin
america america delivery similarly came
up with mercado pago
both of those innovations are aimed at
helping people who do not have credit
cards get access to Internet commerce so
you can go into a little town in the
middle of Brazil I saw one of these in
piracicaba which is like out of a movie
you expect to see the good the bad and
the ugly and their sort of dust rising
and I go into this little shop and
there's someone making a purchase with
cash which the person at the counter
then is inserting into the database of
Mercado Pago so that they can then make
an internet purchase with someone online
well well they didn't have a credit card
and they didn't have access to the
Internet
similarly in China Ali pay has grown
into a fearsome organisation when it
comes to essentially banking the
unbanked now we would not have thought
of that as the reason that Alibaba had
come to exist when people were initially
excited about Alibaba they figured they
were excited about Alibaba because of
e-commerce c2c and b2c and all the other
acronyms you hear about when we're
talking about e-commerce and of course
they've been successful on that front
but there was a new business model also
developed out of that because they ran
into unique challenges in that context
you look in Brazil and you see a retail
chain organization known as magazine Oh
Louisa which looks very different than
any kind of mass retailer you would have
in most other parts of the world and if
you go in as I would advise you to do
sometime if you ever in Brazil you go
into a magazine Luiza you see lower
middle class consumers making their
first major purchase of an appliance
typically for the home maybe a
refrigerator very proud perhaps dressed
in their suit that they would otherwise
only wear to church making this purchase
using the internet sometimes for the
first time there in the store with the
guidance of an associate who's also
proud that she has that job and that
makes her stand out in terms of her
family and their socioeconomic status
these are symptoms that you see in an
economy where millions and millions of
people have been brought out of the
poverty of poverty in the last few years
it's a business model that's set up
around serving a consumer that would
typically be ignored by most retailers
because of their lack of
credit and that being able to solve that
one problem has made magazine Luiza and
many other organizations like them
incredibly successful in this case in
Brazil the American retailers European
retailers the high-end retailers from
much of the rest of Latin America have
not touched these consumers most of the
world's really interesting businesses
were not planned in a row they were
discovered in the process of trying to
implement a plan that never really
worked but instead morphed into
something else that was much more
fantastic than the original plan ever
would have predicted and many of the
people watching this video might have an
experience with that they might think
that's an exceptional experience in fact
though the lives of businesses are very
much like the lives of people they
unfold you know in a way that's almost
haphazard at times because of the
tremendous amount of uncertainty that we
face and just like the life of a person
does not read like a resume neither does
the life of a business read like a
strategic plan instead it typically
unfolds as things are discovered along
the way and as leadership comes to
identify opportunities that maybe they
didn't see at first and then change the
organization to seize those
opportunities and become greater than
they ever could have been so what we're
seeing in some of the most innovative
firms is that leadership focuses less on
planning and much more on that process
of discovery if you want to look at it
this way
discovery Trump's planning and so good
leadership often plans to discover and
looks at that innovation processes where
they put their focus when they're
leading their organization
I sometimes now look at businesses that
are solidly Silicon Valley businesses
and I've been teaching entrepreneurship
in the Silicon Valley now for about 20
years it's been a lot of years seeing
businesses formed here increasingly I'm
seeing Silicon Valley firms being
self-referential a lot of focus on
consumer internet a lot of focus on the
kinds of problems that people in this
very elite group of well-educated
entrepreneurs see as important problems
and not so much of an attention being
paid to the tremendous gains that can be
made from solving problems that come up
in other parts of the world one of the
things we do have in innovative places
like Silicon Valley that is still needed
in many other parts of the world is that
larger infrastructure of institutions
from finance to law supportive business
knowledge and so forth that allows for a
process of failure in an in the effort
to get to the end result most businesses
fail the most innovative business
contexts are marked by large numbers of
failures but unfortunately many parts of
the world still see failure as something
that carries a great deal of stigma with
it as most people know if you go to the
Silicon Valley failure is a normal part
of life
of course people don't want to fail
everyone wishes their innovations could
immediately be successful but it's well
understood that the road to success is
often marked by a series of failures of
course in many parts of the world once
you have a failure your career is
forever marred by that and the shame
that goes with that is often very
difficult so what we need to be able to
do is take the business necessity that
we see being created in many different
parts of the world and combine that with
a tolerance for the innovation process
and all its messiness that we see in
places like the Silicon Valley